um i think it's uh i think it's right  that the um  public selected representatives are  trying to uh figure out  what happened and the lessons to be  learned i hope you'll get all the senior  people involved  uh in here to to speak to you about it  the truth is that senior ministers  senior officials  senior advisers like me  fell disastrously short of the standards  that the public has a right to expect  of its government in a crisis like this  when the public needed us most the  government failed  and i'd like to say to all the families  of those who who died and necessarily  how sorry i am for the mistakes that  were made and for my own mistakes of  that